[Music]
it is III 2018 my name is Jake and I'm
here with Kevin yeah hey what game do we
have we have what the Gulf it's a
physics based golfing game it's very
silly
I guess the premise of it is every
course is different so you golf once
like right here the first thing that's
got with golf like a regular golf and
then we go to some other kind of weird
goofy antics and I guess every every
course is different and I guess one of
the features that these guys are touting
is it won't make you better at golf so
if you're worried about that wonderful
let's take a look let's jump right in so
we got these cats here I'm gonna try and
so it looks like it's a hit the mouse
you can kind of move it around and you
can just a sensitive looks like it's
pretty straightforward from those games
that you can just look at and figure out
what to do so I'm gonna try to get these
kitties just to see what I noticed I
played a good amount of this just to
test it and it is it just goes off the
rails very quickly so this is the first
one where it gets weak there we go we
lost it or not we're not golfing the
ball we're golfing the man so the these
guys are total goof balls yeah this one
were actually the golf club so yeah so
we're not golfing the ball golf in the
club okay so let's try and golf balls
everywhere yeah it gets it gets breached
oh wow there we go this game could be a
little tricky I could see ya next camera
yeah I from what I can tell you can
pretty much like take as many swings as
you want but if it falls off you got to
start over so I do see it is tracking
par at the top they're like I see a four
yeah man that six camera angles just
killing man
I'm totally eating it right here
but yeah so tribe and basically
contacted me and they said how would you
like to play our golf game at e3 and I
said I don't have to play golf they said
good so I guess that's kind of the idea
here is oh all right
this is trickier than it looks it's an
oblong strange object yeah yeah all
right we have pool okay so this one is
good I did play this one okay oh I'm
golfing the house now
like I blocked it oh you can walk we can
walk the cards and destroy the cards I
kind of want to take them out so the the
team who made this were they based their
from Denmark okay and they told me that
the art director basically never leaves
the house he lives in the woods
somewhere and they they just kind of
tell him about the world and then he
designed the game oh so he's just kind
of off on his own I'm signing it it's a
nice red explosive barrels here I like
that yeah I know that's fitting that you
should try bouncing off that rock see if
you can bounce a rock and ricochet it in
yeah okay oh there we go nice guidance
there's you know I wanna hit this
pineapple I just yeah ricochet off the
pineapple Oh what okay so they
definitely they told me a few things on
this game and they're definitely right
every course is different it's all
different because every single time it's
pretty pretty hilarious definitely the
the fact that the hole moved was very
good I like a little text in between
sausage goes so wait we're doing soccer
I guess time slows down
Oh quick yeah you gotta keep you got to
do it quick so I guess there's no way
you can do it on one there right no I
don't think so
so let's try and I'm gonna take this
little kid out just cuz yeah
wait wait that little kids taking me out
that kids button oh my gosh you can just
totally I didn't get part 1/5 but oh oh
ton of them now huh okay okay I think
you've got the right strategy I don't
think I should even worry about the top
number I'm just gonna completely ignore
and just fly this thing just kick it in
the air Oh change of perspective all of
a sudden can I go
oh okay so this is uh oh okay my ideas
here these guys got yeah I saw so just
to clarify you how do you know the
developers I actually don't know them
they just they just basically emailed me
just crazy
didn't work guys say hey you want to
play this game for us and I said sure
I'll play it for you cool why not like
I'll do it yeah it's like I'll take the
chance to play at e3 like this physics
little little like hook here it's fun
it's kind of like spider golf there you
go yeah hole-in-one
that wasn't a hole in it yeah I'll take
it
no this is my the dirt a hole in a
number I get it wait Han I'm not gonna
go for it someone take the dog out or
that what is this a toaster what are you
you know the golf ball anymore what is
that yeah thank you really look like
there's like a piece of dirt so um I saw
two that they they have a like a
superhot tribute it's called super putt
or you have to dodge bullets as the golf
ball and it has the slo-mo time the full
superhot mechanics I hope we get there
yeah I know that sounds awesome right I
think actually me a 2d oh yeah some
marios like world 1:1 or a mario
reference definitely and samir yeah
whatever
I want to go to Oh like this guy's face
here
I know it's cracks me up all right oh
wait can I get it again keep hitting
okay so what if I can break all the
blocks like I wonder if there's like a
power mushroom or something of that
nature here no this guy real likes to
jump
yeah he does okay she's got to give it
all right he can't break him okay yeah
it won't break on his head there he's
like he's like a little kind of Goomba
guy not quite like almost a little bird
this is not a golf game this is
definitely not a golf game anymore what
the golf seriously yeah I'm gonna try
and see if I can go into the pipe it's
tricky it's not easy actually it started
out really easy but didn't they they
really like to go see no it was worth
the try try oh I got him yeah this is
pretty good one where else we'll get a
new here as far as these these game
references we get portals it's glad it's
gonna make an appearance
yeah oh okay I see I got it I got it
they're easy you could probably get that
one on one shot but oh okay okay I got
this is interest time it so it's through
the red one so I'm gonna lead it off so
it's probably gonna be like okay so
let's try it it's moving a little faster
than perfect nailed it second hit nailed
that one space it off
oh you have to wait I think is orbit oh
no I thought I was gonna catch orbit
nailed it though but you got it I don't
know that I don't know how but I'm that
seems like face space physics oh my
kitty now I think so
oh I just love I just love always like
this static off shake it just cracks me
up perfect putt beautiful perfect full
alright I got some more explosive
barrels here I'm just gonna go right
back and oh yeah oh hey he's fine for
again yeah he's okay you can take and
kitties and trees multiple different
okay so this one you can't go can do air
control of how he has the ball yeah I
know you think you're gonna do it and
then it's like wait you do it no no
patrol I got no okay so the golfers a
little more hardcore together you gotta
take this one a little more carefully
but I have to hit the barrels I can't
believe the barrels there I know it's
like the video game OCD if there's a red
barrel even if there's no in there you
have to shoot it hard centigrade okay
alright for real this time real this
time
barely make me go a little too far so
I'll be careful
kind of just take it slow oh sorry
kiddies take it slow and kind of just
that's it alright let's give it one more
go go one more go I'll be really careful
just kind of inch the golf for a long I
have so tethered just discipline I
really want to just do it you guys just
play him yeah just fling him let's go
he survived he did I know he's a he's a
tough guy
this golfer soccer ball oh my god man
hit then oh so cool for coming in and
showing us this game this looks a
kilometre thanks for having me so
they're gonna release it on Mac OS steam
so Windows Linux they want to give on
other platforms as well and they're
still fun to figure that out but
currently they're just announcing on
those three platforms cool any idea when
they're late summer late okay so soon
soonish cool yeah well you can check
this out soon thank you again Kevin and
for more III coverage you already in the
right place